all right let's bring out our final
contestant it's tracy hi tracy
hi tracy
okay tracy we have been blown away by
the talent so far so where are you from
um well i'm tracy martin i'm from west
point georgia
and i'm the mom of three crazy kids
and my talent is walking on my hands
while saying the alphabet backwards that
old thing yeah it's kind of random
so this is two skills i've always been
able to do okay but the way it came
together was
when i had you know i wanted to remember
when you could do two things and thought
what if i get them at the same time
when my kids were in middle school we
had 4-h camp that i was always a
chaperone for on these field trips and
so they'd have talent shows and the kids
would say we want the parents to be in
the talent show so
i would come out and say
i'm from a planet where everything is
backwards and upside down and my name is
icart which is tracy spelled backwards
and then i do my little trick so
honestly the only people that have seen
this are seventh and eighth graders okay
in the woods so that's it i mean this is
a higgins talent i
love it and that is all about hidden
talent yes and this is what we call an
exclusive you're not gonna see this
anywhere but the new barrymore show okay
um well i'm really excited to see it
tracy yeah all right here we go
z y x w v u t s r q p o n m l k j
i h g f e d c b a
now i know it
z two a drew barrymore show
[Applause]
thank you tracy thank you
why don't you guys all come up here and
it's a time to declare a winner uh one
at a time we'll hold up our pedals with
a vote but of course
you're all winners in our eyes and i i i
gosh oh gosh this is just i oh my god is
there something with everyone
i guess i'll go here it's so hard
because i love everybody i hate them
[Applause]
wow
also good um
i
i think the one that i'm the most
impressed by because i want to be able
to do it and i think it's really good
cardio
i know maybe everyone will get a vote i
mean i could you're the tiebreaker i
could vote for any of you you know um
you all wowed us and so i'm gonna say at
the end of the day
just because of the pure energy
i'm gonna go with burning dead
[Applause]
yeah i agree
everybody yeah i i'm not good at this
because i just enjoy what all of you do
and thank you so much for coming here
today and having fun with that
[Applause]
thank you so much for coming here and
doing that
um be sure to catch seth on stars in the
house which benefits the actors fund um
and you've been so good and so
supportive of them i love the actress if
people don't know the actress fund is
for anybody in the arts actor singer
dancers everybody backstage in front
anyone can go to the actressfun.org and
get help paying their rent paying their
medical bills so if you know any artists
tell them
and check out his website to see where
he's performing next that's right
[Music]
you